4 fondiaria ya deux monstres sacrés se
rend compte ça fait des étincelles c'est
ce qu'a pu constater constaté martin
lawrence thein sein
lancement à la jambe et martin lawrence
sur la wii martin lawrence quand il vous
a vu avec will smith
non mais c'est lui le monstre sacré
marqué à ses côtés vous bat on a fait ce
lancement mahdi lancement jean-mi donc
du coup je répète non merci
et donc du coup voilà vous avez fait un
petit sketch pour le lancement de la
régie a bad boys et postures est resté
très drôle exactement c'est vrai que
j'ai rencontré will smith et martin
lawrence
hier c'était à l'hôtel ritz le palace
magnifique et c'est vrai que je me suis
régalé mais je n'appelle pas dans ces
cas là et les deux les deux
exceptionnels et will smith assez la
casse je vous le dis je les adorais
d'ailleurs je lui ai dit on va peut-être
se voit quoi avec will smith
c'est à dire à se voir comme un par
écran interposé
[Musique]
cyril hanouna à bien vous remettez ni
hanouna la th elle était bidon des plus
tarder
arrêter maintenant je suis ici tu vois
acheteurs du tabasco et vous alors là
les deux stars qu'est-ce que vous
deveniez toujours dans le cinéma comme
geneviève est top et on fait du sport ou
quoi pour vous avez pas bougé ute on
trouve vous a fait plaisir pour trouver
dans cinq ans après l'arrêt du mouvement
je suis franchement les gars bien reçu
et je vous sers un truc et et si vous
prenez un truc c'est pour moi c'est
gratuit en expert de l'apéritif à l'eau
folha hier yoyo il ya des billets est de
20 soit oui c'est certain
[Applaudissements]
ses marques
non franchement
[Musique]